[Music]
every time you eat a piece of bread or
drink a glass of beer you are
participating in what might be depending
on how strict you are about your
definitions one of the longest-running
microbiology experiments in human
history while the earliest scientific
studies of microbes usually go back only
a few centuries when it comes to yeast
the microbe at the core of some of our
favorite foods and drinks
well those past few centuries barely
scratched the surface but before we get
to that history let's start with some of
the basic biology yeast are a fungus
though unlike many in that kingdom they
don't grow the branching hyphy that
characterize organisms like mushrooms
instead yeast grow primarily through a
process of asexual reproduction called
budding them while there are many yeast
species found among different fungal
phyla perhaps the most well-known is
Saccharomyces cerevisiae which you might
see labeled as brewers yeast or baker's
yeast along with a few other yeasts
these various strains of s cerevisiae
are what we've come to rely on for our
beer wine and bread and all through the
magic of fermentation yeast like many
organisms rely on different metabolic
pathways to break down sugar and create
energy these processes usually rely on
oxygen but to deal with situations where
oxygen may be less readily available or
some of their key metabolic processes
are shut down
yeast turned to alcoholic fermentation
fermentation helps the yeast get the
energy it needs but the particular
chemical path they follow also produces
ethanol and carbon dioxide the East
doesn't need these byproducts in fact
too much ethanol could be toxic for them
but what is waste to a yeast is treasure
to us
and that shift in metabolic activity has
been making our bread rise and our
brains woozy for millennia
molecular studies of pottery jars found
in China found that they may have held
some kind of fermented beverage as far
back as 7000 BCE and archaeological
evidence has turned up for leavened
bread from 2000 BCE in Egypt and a
thousand BCE and northwestern China it's
easy to see why our use of yeast has
persisted for millennia to quote one
group of scientists it helped us make
food and drinks with a quote enriched
sensorial palate and also a quote you
Florian affect the long-standing
ubiquity of yeast also emphasizes how
mysterious their origins are we don't
actually know how yeast became involved
with our cooking we just know that it
was ancient likely starting with wine
and would come to span continents
potentially spreading through trade the
results were food and drinks produced
through a series of observations about
how factors like temperature time and
air might affect the final product
to quote Samuel Johnson's 18th century
dictionary bomb a type of yeast is quote
the firmament put into drink to make it
work and into bread to lighten and swell
it at the time they didn't know what was
actually in yeast or how it worked to
shape those results we just knew it was
a thing that provided something somehow
moreover the earliest glimpses of yeast
under the microscope seemed to support
the idea that yeast was just some sort
of chemical a fermenting agent not a
biological entity of its own when Antony
van Leeuwenhoek observed yeast in the
17th century he thought they were just
bits of globular particles against the
new and incredible bits of life he was
seeing for the first
time through the microscope yeast seemed
useful but ultimately unliving but over
the next few centuries as more
scientists worked to try and understand
how fermentation actually worked they
identified not just the chemical
reactions that shaped the process but
that yeast was an actual living organism
essential to fermentation eventually
Louis Pasteur would put all the pieces
together publishing a paper called
the memoir of the fermentation of
alcohol or something like that but in
French it was published in 1857 and it
established the interplay between
chemistry and biology that allowed yeast
to turn to alcoholic fermentation to
survive you would also later uncover
another form of fermentation carried out
by bacteria which is called lactic acid
fermentation
Pasteur's work didn't just change our
understanding of how bread was made it
would go on to inform our understanding
of germ theory and how the invisible
world of microbes connects to the grim
realities of disease from this early
history yeast have gone on to become
perhaps one of the most studied
eukaryotic organisms in modern
biological research Saccharomyces
cerevisiae in particular has had an
illustrious research career in 1996 its
genome was fully sequenced making it the
first eukaryotic organism to be
genetically mapped out part of what
makes yeast such great research
organisms is that they are easy to grow
and manipulate both through
environmental and genetic means which
has allowed us to use them to study
everything from DNA replication to prion
diseases in the same way that cultures
have refined the ways we use yeast in
our food and drinks scientists have
refined the way we use yeast in our lab
experiments
they've even developed genetic
engineering techniques that repurpose
yeast to brew the ingredients for
everything from perfumes to anti
malarial drugs when you consider just
how far we've come with yeast you might
begin to wonder did we domesticate them
after all our early days of yeast use
likely coincided with our early days of
plant and animal domestication so in the
same way that we've come to rely on
domesticated animals for food and labor
maybe yeast or our microbial workhorses
the answer to that question is one that
scientists are actually still studying
in part because the history of yeast is
so large and mysterious and in part
because domestication
has a very specific definition in these
conversations one paper we found
describes it as quote human selection
and breeding of wild species to obtain
cultivated variants that thrive in
man-made environments but behave
sub-optimally in nature that's quite a
number of nuanced requirements to check
off but with this definition in mind
beer yeast seems to show the most
evidence for having been domesticated
which is likely connected to specific
aspects of the brewing process that have
limited the exposure of the domesticated
yeast to wild yeast but all yeasts
considered the genetic analysis of beer
yeast strains show that this
domestication is actually relatively
recent as in it only happened a few
centuries ago while it did happen before
we even knew that yeast was a living
thing that we were domesticating it
still came long after we started using
yeast to make beer leaving much of the
organisms history still a mystery
it is often tempting to think that we
have a microbial world and a human world
that intersect only in chemical
reactions and biological connections but
yeast reminds us that microbes are more
than just a scientific reality they are
a cultural one even when we didn't know
they were around yeast have created our
foods shaped our traditions and both
bonded and divided us and how we use and
change yeast will only continue to shape
our lives their future tide so much to
our own is every bit as grand and
mysterious as their past has been thank
you for coming on this journey with us
as we explore the unseen world that
surrounds us we've been making videos on
this channel for just over a year now
and we want to thank all of you for
supporting us during our first year to
celebrate that we're adding a new tear
to our patreon as well as a journey to
the micro cosmos discord in the hopes of
opening up our community to more people
we often see people asking microscopy
questions in the video comments which we
don't always have time or information to
answer but we love seeing other
commenters jump in and answer those
questions but we also know that YouTube
comments aren't always the easiest or
best place to have those conversations
so in our discord we're going to have
spaces for you to share any of those
questions you might have along with your
own microscopy or just some of those
good good tardigrade memes
additionally micro cosmos team members
like me and our master of microscopes
James will be there from time to time to
discuss the most recent episode or
answer any lingering questions you might
have for us about the channel our new $2
patreon tier will give you access to the
discord our patreon feed and the monthly
hour-long video featuring just uncut
footage and background music and we also
have the $8 tier where in addition to
the discord
on video you will receive weekly digital
wallpapers and your name will be
featured in the credits just like all of
these people that you're seeing on the
screen right now to learn how to become
a patron you can go to
patreon.com/scishow regardless of
whether you join our patreon community
we are so grateful to all of you for
watching and appreciating our channel to
see more from our aforementioned master
of microscopes James check out Jam and
germs on Instagram and to see more from
us well there's probably a subscribe
button somewhere nearby
[Music]